ce matin avec nous ils blain député la
république en marche de la 14e
circonscription du rhône jean marc flipo
également porte-parole de debout la
france
[Musique]
bonjour messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce matin sur ft france pour revenir sur
l'actualité de ces dernières heures et
je vous propose de commencer avec la
prise de parole des manuels macro et
hier sur l'afghanistan et notamment sur
les conséquences en france de cette
crise avec d'éventuels risques
d'attentats et pour le chef de l'état y
ne faut pas confondre les risques
terroristes et l'immigration et on
souvient le lien avait été fait il ya vu
un débat notamment à droite il y a
quelques mois dans le contexte actuel il
a raison de faire cette distinction
emmanuel macron jean-marc chip on
commence avec vous
macron dont d'enfoncer les portes
ouvertes ça fait ce débat là ça fait des
années qu'il est ce sur le tpiy sauf que
il ya quinze jours de cela on a décelé
dans les personnes rapatriées faire
rapatrier transférer plus exactement en
france depuis l'organiste ans on a
trouvé cinq personnes qui avaient des
liens avec les talibans donc ce débat
est plus que jamais d'actualité c'est
bien évidemment il n'y a pas d'identité
entre un migrant es un terroriste
le risque de voir arriver massivement en
france des terroristes en provenance de
territoires tels que l'afghanistan
l'irak et la syrie et est toujours aussi
toujours aussi important yves blein vous
vous entendez cette crainte de jean-marc
chipeau entre cette arrivée attendue un
massif de réfugiés et le risque
d'attentats le lien il se fait pour vous
je crois que je me devrai d'autres
expressions de d'arrivée massive
il s'agit pour le moment d'offrir
l'asile d'accueillir des afghans qui ont
collaboré avec nos services et que notre
armée quand nous étions en afghanistan
parce que ce sont des personnes qui
risquent pour leur vie donc pour maman
c'est de cela qu'on parle que
le risque existe que certains profitent
de ses expatriés a su d'une certaine
façon pour s'infiltrer dans des vagues
qui arriverait il errait la preuve que
cinq personnes ont été démasqués comme
ayant eu des relations avec les talibans
mais ça veut aussi dire que les services
de renseignement français les services
françaises sur place plus mal temps
malheureusement bien sûr mais il a pu
arriver actuellement pour le travail de
recherche de dépistage de ce dossier
risque à l'aller je pense que sur ce
plan on peut leur faire confiance alors
emmanuel macron qui à 10,1 selon ses
mots qu'il y aura une pression tout de
même sur notre capacité à accueillir les
afghans valérie pécresse s'est exprimé
hier sur cette question regarder
le sujet il est clair nous ne pouvons
accueillir michel rocard disait toute la
misère du monde aujourd'hui on le sait
le défi de la france c'est d'arrêter
l'immigration incontrôlée je propose
qu'on généralise l'asile à la frontière
c'est une demande obligatoire d'asile
dans nos ambassades
une bonne idée selon vous jean marc
flipo que les démarches administratives
se fasse en amour pour les demandes
d'asile dans l'est dans les ambassades
françaises
écoutez je crois je vais envoyer un
bulletin d'adhésion à debout la france
avait un peu crest puisque c'est une
mesure que l'on propose depuis depuis au
moins cinq ans c'est bien et c'est une
évidence les demandes d'asile doivent
être doivent être réalisés à l'étranger
ne serait ce que parce que pas prenant
l'exemple toujours de ces cinq personnes
qui ont été effectivement identifiés par
les services elles sont toujours sur le
territoire national des personnes qui
sont identifiés comme étant à risque sur
le territoire français demeurent sur le
territoire français donc on est bien
obligé de on est bien obligé de créer
les conditions de se prémunir contre
contre ce genre de risque maintenant
encore une fois madame pécresse sans
découvrir une situation qui existe
depuis depuis des années et comme disait
comme disait albert einstein c'est pas
les gens qui ont créé les problèmes qui
vont les résoudre les républicains ont
créé pour beaucoup les conditions de ce
problème et ce qu'ils vont permettre à
un dernier mot pour compléter sa la
phrase de madame pécresse qui cite à
michel rocard michel rocard a ajouté que
la france devrait devait prendre sa part
et la france a pris sa part déjà la
france accueille à peu près dix mille
afghans par an sur les dernières années
la france a laissé 89 de ses fils en
terre organes qui sont morts et plus de
500 blessés yves blein cette idée de
traiter les deux les demandes d'asile
dans les ambassades à l'extérieur en
amont des arrivées est ce que c'est une
piste que la république en marche
pourrait étudier
vous savez la vie jeudi à la normalité
des choses c'est celle ci le problème
tels que le téléphone multi pas madame
pécresse sait que les phénomène des
migrations
sont pas aussi simple que cela si les
personnes qui tentent de traverser la
méditerranée sur un bateau
allait s'adresser à notre ambassade au
niger au mali etc les problèmes se
poseraient pas je pense que
l'acte n'a difficultés qui se posent à
nous aujourd'hui et le président macro
la pause et dans son intervention c'est
le problème de l'immigration - illégal
c'est le problème des canaux mafieux qui
favorise l'immigration illégale et vous
imaginez bien que ceux-ci qui vont pas
aller toquer à la porte de l'ambassade
de france pour demander les documents
administratifs nécessaires
dans ces langues derrière donc le sait
c'est un peu le monde des bisounours à
qu'elle décrit mme pécresse
ça fonctionne pas comme ça dans la vraie
vie et du coup derrière ces gens qui
arrivent sur le territoire français
qu'est ce qu'on en fait
on a un devoir d'accueil on a un devoir
de d'examiner la situation parce qu'ils
sont partis de leur pays d'origine parce
qu'il y est vraiment en danger c'est
qu'il ya dans certaines situations cela
est vrai et puis il ya des situations où
leur demande n'est pas fondée donc la
logique c'est évidemment qu'elles qu'ils
retournent chez eux qui ne sont pas
content a dit chez eux il a
régulièrement aujourd'hui des personnes
qui ont les pieds dam d'un
accompagnement sont ne pas suffisamment
par rapport au stock pardon de le dire
comme ça de personne concernée mais les
choses se font au fil de l'eau dans cet
esprit là alors parmi les craintes liées
à l'émigration il y en a une caf pas mal
buzz et un sur les réseaux sociaux comme
on dit celle du député européen jordan
bardella il s'exprimer hier regarder
je n'aime pas ce mois de grand
remplacement parce qu'il n'est pas clair
c'est un slogan très intellectuel mais
il pointe une réalité qui est juste
allez vous balader dans tous les
quartiers où j'ai grandi en seine saint
denis willy à un basculement
démographique qui pourrait faire
craindre que la france change de visage
dans quelques années et c'est déjà en
train d'arriver
jean marc flipo c'est une crainte pour
vous aussi que la france change de
visage
c'est par une crainte que pour moi je
crois que c'est gérard collomb c'est ma
mémoire est bonne qui dit parler de
submersion migratoire donc c'est une
austin réalité encore une fois ça sert à
rien de se bander les yeux il ya un réel
problème migratoire en france à l'heure
actuelle
monsieur blain faisait faisait état de
reconduite à la frontière ces
reconduites à la frontières ne sont
quasiment jamais réaliser je crois qu'à
90% de déboutés du droit d'asile qui
demeurent sur le territoire national
comment voulez vous dans ces conditions
que l'immigration se tarissent moi je le
rappelle même en 2016 vous aviez le
commissaire européen aux migrations qui
était de mémoire monsieur avramopoulos
qui déclarait publiquement dans la
tribune de genève que l'europe avait
besoin de 6 millions d'immigrés dont qui
passait comment déjà aux pays
exportateurs de pardon de présenter
comme ça mais c'est c'est dans ces
termes que ça se posent au pays
exportateurs de millions il passait
commande de six millions de travailleurs
pour l'union européenne on peut pas
continuer avec un discours comme ça
c'est pas possible il faut déjà que
l'europe parce que c'est elle qui est en
tant de monde il faut d'abord que
l'union européenne pose clairement comme
comme préalable pardon mais on affiche
complet c'était jacques renard on a du
chômage en europe il faut qu'on règle le
problème de chômage on a un problème
d'assimilation des populations
étrangères qui sont déjà sur notre sol
il faut impérativement que l'on règle ce
problème d'assimilation c'est pas en
rentrant encore on parle de 500 mille
afghans qui potentiellement pourrait
prendre le chemin bleu parmi ces gens là
combien seront assimilables est ce qu'un
paysan pachtoune qui a été élevé dans le
dans la rigueur de l'islam peut peut
s'accommoder dans un dans le dans le 11e
arrondissement je pas sûr ils veulent un
ca se doivent gérer au niveau de l'union
européenne comme l'a rappelé le
président de la république emmanuel
macron donc comment est ce que lui a
justement peut mettre que doit mettre en
place celui à face à l'accueil de ces
personnes
je crois que gains moyens et la question
s'est déjà posée par passer
je suis accusée de répartition de la
charge
migrateurs au sein de l'europe et entre
les différents pays qui est composante
très sincèrement
quand on parle de 510 personnes je pense
qu'on est quand même pas tout à fait
dans les clous de la réalité mais si on
le rapporte à la population européenne
500 millions mais de mémoire et quelques
d'habitants on parle là de 1%
même pas de 0,1 pour cent par an de la
population donc on est patient des
chiffres qui sont aussi significatives
que ça si la répartition en fonction du
volume de population de chaque pays et
justement fait donc je pense que c'est
pour ça que le président a insisté sur
ça je suis ok semble-t-il quelques
bonnes âmes sur la nécessité de se
préparer
c'est à dire qu'il y ait un dialogue
suffisent entre les différents pays
européens pour que chacun ne tient pas
et lui a lié un certain 10 heures marché
en accueillir tant d'autres moi je le
ferais un plaisir dans tout ça ça n'a
pas de sens il faut que l'europe
solidaire des afghans qui veulent
quitter leur pays parce qu'il y à des
risques de persécution pour eux parce
qu'il ya des parts et d'enseignement
pour rester dans ping pas évidemment
cautionner cette situation et ne pas la
regarder en face mais il faut que
l'effort soit équitable par chacun des
pays d'europe et encore on est bientôt
elle deviendra un sit-in une question
d'une hypothèse et si l'immersion pense
qu'il faut problème
pourquoi serait-ce à l'europe de prendre
en charge alors que c'est le pakistan
qui pourra pour beaucoup est responsable
de la situation de l'effondrement de du
gouvernement avoue enfin pardon et tout
un tas de pays entre l'afghanistan et
l'europe qui peuvent très bien prendre
en charge ces réfugiés pourquoi ça
serait systématiquement à l'europe de
qui a fait le job qui a envoyé des
troupes là-bas pour stabiliser le pays
qui a déversé des milliards d'euros sur
l'afghanistan comment verse de l'eau sur
du sable pourquoi est ce que ce serait
encore à l'europe de prendre en charge
ces réfugiés je suis désolé moi je vois
aucune raison logique à cela yves là on
ne peut pas s'accrocher l'afghanistan et
vous comprenez bien pourquoi l'accueil
par exemple des personnes qui ont
collaboré avec eux l'armée française
lorsqu'elle était sur place qui lui ont
servi des clients
sérieux pour le moment c'est de ces
personnes n'a ton cas alors messieurs
dans l'actualité également c'est la
crise sanitaire bien évidemment est dans
la lignée du chef de l'état gabriella
talent n'exclut pas la mise en place de
la vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
français finalement est-ce que ce serait
plus clair ou pas pour vous
mais jean-marc chipeau
mais on parle de quoi quand quand on a
voté le pass sanitaires monsieur vérone
juré ses grands dieux que c'était très
provisoire et que et que ça devait
s'arrêter au 15 novembre absolument
avant ça je répète que tous ces gens là
nous répétait que jamais jamais jamais
ont narré de passes sanitaire dans notre
pays pour les actes de la vie
quotidienne alors je suis désolé mais on
demande toujours plus aux français ça va
ça va s'arrêter quand ça va s'arrêter
quand aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que l'immunité
collective par la vaccination est une
chimère
donc ça veut dire quoi ça qu'on
s'installe dans un système de pass
sanitaire de contrôle social à la
chinoise en permanence aujourd'hui les
doubles vacciner vont être logés à la
même enseigne que les non vaccinés
d'hyères enfin jusqu'à ce qu'il reçoive
une troisième dos ça va s'arrêter quand
tout ça c'est pas possible on peut tout
simplement pas
bâtir l'avenir d'un pays sous un régime
de contrainte
vaccinale sanitaire permanente c'est pas
possible il ya des valeurs cardinales de
notre république que sont la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité et tout le reste
des lois tout le reste de beurre comment
dire de l'organisation du corps social
doit doit se soumettre à ses valeurs
cardinales ou alors effectivement c'est
qu'on a changé de régime ils veulent à
vous les comprenez ces craintes liées au
passé ni terre
c'est l'image est alors à titre
personnel j suis plutôt favorable à
l'obligation
de vaccination parce que qui trouve
vraiment qu'on est sur des débats un peu
l'impression réaliste parfois un truc en
france par exemple et c'est vrai à peu
près partout qui s'appelle le code de la
route qui nous impose de vous arrêter un
carrefour franchir une ligne blanche
kantienne chez août voilà etc et c'est
pas libération abominable des libertés
c'est juste que produire en société et a
besoin d'un certain nombre de règles et
que selon l'expression de la liberté des
uns s'arrête là où commence celle des
autres moi je ne conçois pas aujourd'hui
alors que il est démontré que la
vaccination n'est inutile que l terme et
d'éviter des instits alisation ainsi
elle permet d'éviter et ses domaines de
contamination de masse que la
vaccination est obligatoire moi je suis
comme tout le monde d'oxydé des maps
huit ans en france par le bcg et je
pense que ça a permis notamment
d'éradiquer un certain nombre d'épidémie
un tiers en fait beaucoup de dégâts en
leur temps donc j'avoue que je trouve ce
débat un peu ce rallye parce que les
départements dans les français ne s'y
trompent pas puisque 46 millions d'entre
eux sont des avec signé je pense qu'on
attendra 50 millions jean-marc six ans
faire vacciner les derniers et qui ne
serait pas convaincu que ce sera utile
finalement mettre en place une règle de
vaccination obligatoire est ce que ça ne
serait pas plus clair pour tout le monde
comme on vient on viens de l'entendre
mais ça n'a jamais été fait monsieur
voie de la vaccination obligatoire dont
on parlait des vaccinations pour des
maladies infantiles c'est à dire sonder
les enfants sont directement touchées
par ces maladies là sont eux qui sont la
cible aujourd'hui on parle de vacciner
des gens qui ne sont pas la cible
on exige de les vacciner alors même
qu'il est aujourd'hui démontré que la
vaccination n'empêche pas la
transmission pas c'est ça qui est fou et
quant aux comparaisons oiseuses avec le
code de la route je suis désolé le code
de la route n'est pas attentatoire aux
libertés fondamentales aux libertés
individuelles et ce à tous les tous les
organismes qui ont été consultés dans
l'élaboration de la loi que ce soit le
conseil d'état conseil constitutionnel
la commission mixte paritaire le
défenseur des droits acceptera tout le
monde là tout le monde l'a bien noté
sauf qu'ils avaient considéré à l'époque
que l'exigence de santé publique à
laquelle était présentée par le
gouvernement a été supérieure à celle
des gîtes à sète au respect des libertés
individuelles
mais à la limite c'est plus le cas
maintenant puisque vous prétendez que 50
millions de français sont vaccinés votre
très bien donc ça veut dire que le
gouvernement a atteint 100 a atteint son
but quand est-ce qu'on arrête que parce
sanitaires le pass sanitaire la
vaccination n'empêche pas la
transmission de la maladie les personnes
des enfants les adolescents les
personnes jeunes ne risque pas de
contracter des formes graves de la
maladie on ne vaccine pas des gens en
dehors d'un protocole de bénéfice risque
voilà ça n'a jamais été fait encore dans
le monde et dans l'histoire de la
vaccination et là je suis désolé si on
commence aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'on
a une autre idée derrière la tête mais
ce qu'il ne reste quelques secondes
quelques instants juste peut-être votre
réaction sur une proposition qui fait
polémique ces dernières heures celle
d'eric woerth regardez
je propose d'étudier l'opportunité pour
les propriétaires de résidences
secondaires qui seront les seuls à payer
la taxe d'habitation de voter aux
élections municipales sur leurs deux
lieux de vie renforcer la démocratie
c'est aussi faire évoluer nos modes de
participation alors à un double vote aux
municipales pour les propriétaires de
résidences secondaires une idée d'eric
woerth est ce que vous soutenez et
dublin
personnellement ce crétin parce que
j'estime l'impôt local c'est quoi c'est
contribuer à la caisse commune que l'on
de la collectivité locale est donc
l'expression sans vote choisir ceux qui
ont moins la gérer d'une certaine façon
donc le trou je lis des livres des
proches qui vident jean marc flipo et ça
sera le mot de la fin pour vous oui je
sais par la force la force là d'autres
tripatouiller la démocratie je pense
qu'on va vraiment arriver une fente de
bouillie aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe on voit que lecteur à une défiance
vraiment très forte à l'égard du
politique on voit des taux d'abstention
record
partout je pense que si on veut ramener
vraiment l'électeur dans l'isoloir faut
arrêter avec ce concours de enfin vous
allez dire des âneries mais oui je pense
que c'est ça il ya des choses qui sont
peut-être plus apport plusieurs gens
d'affaires comme par exemple de
reconnaître le vote blanc de faire de
faire rejouer le scrutin lorsque le vote
blanc est majoritaire éliminer les
candidats qui se sont présentés date de
rentrée le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne dans la constitution voilà
deux de redonner au référendum
toute la place qu'il avait lors lorsque
la cinquième la constitution de la vème
république a été rédigé voilà ça ce sont
des choses concrètes qui remettent le
citoyen au coeur du débat qui évite
d'inventer une usine à glace par seconde
en tout cas merci à tous les deux
d'avoir des battues sereinement ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france merci à
vous yves blein député la république en
marge de la 14e circonscription du rhône
merci à vous jean marc chipeau
porte-parole de debout la france